und wir kommen moment zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um die
öffentliche gesundheitsversorgung
einerseits hat die fdp-fraktion hier
drei anträge eingereicht in dem sie
unter anderem fordert dass die
weltgesundheitsorganisation reformiert
wird und die fraktion von bündnis 90/die
grünen beschäftigt sich mit der
wissenschaft von public health da geht
es darum wie kann durch zum beispiel
politische und wirtschaftliche eingriffe
dass zum beispiel die umweltbedingungen
oder die gesundheitsversorgung so
verbessert werden dass eben dann die
menschen in einer gesellschaft gesünder
sind und gar nicht erst krank werden
erster redner ist allerdings jetzt für
die unionsfraktion alexander kraus ich
möchte mit einem herzlichen dankeschön
beginnen an die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst
wir haben gerade in der pandemie erlebt
dass sie über die grenzen der eigenen
leistungsfähigkeit hinausgegangen sind
nicht nur an einem tag sondern wirklich
über wochen und monate
das war eine sehr respektable leistung
der mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter tot im
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst zur
beschreibung der situation gehört aber
leider auch dass der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst seinen aufgaben
bereits vor der pandemie nicht
ausreichend gerecht werden konnte wenn
der einschulungsuntersuchungen denken
wenn wir ein gesundheitsförderung denken
der grund liegt in der personellen
unterbesetzung es gibt derzeit 2500
ärzte im öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
vor 25 jahren waren dass 50 prozent mehr
deswegen war es richtig deswegen ein
herzliches dankeschön an den
bundesgesundheitsminister im märz im
september den pakt für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst auf den weg zu bringen
der bund der eigentlich keine
zuständigkeit für diesen bereich hat
gibt dennoch vier milliarden euro für
den öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst für
personal für digitalisierung für moderne
strukturen
wir haben noch herausforderungen wenn
ich an dieser software zur kontakt
nachverfolgung banker
derzeit nutzt nur knapp die hälfte der
gesundheitsämter dieses system
die bundesländer haben zugesagt bis ende
februar alle gesundheitsämter
anzuschließen man muss jetzt kein
prophet sein um zu wissen dass das
vermutlich nicht dazu kommen wird was
schade ist ich würde mir wünschen dass
gerade die landkreise dass die länder
dort wesentlich mehr dampf machen damit
das gelingt deswegen wir sollten beraten
wieder öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
gestärkt werden kann und wie ihr von
bundesseite mehr einfluss nehmen können
damit der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
auch wirklich seine arbeit macht allein
mit guten worten und großzügigen
geldgeschenken wird das auch in zukunft
nicht gelingen
das waren für mich jetzt die
kurzfristigen notwendigkeiten aber ich
finde wir müssen den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst auch in einer
langfristperspektive betrachten und wir
brauchen den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst für einen
paradigmenwechsel in der
gesundheitspolitik nämlich dass wir den
fokus stärker darauf ausrichten wie
menschen gesund bleiben können
da spielt der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst wirklich eine
schlüsselrolle
unsere gesundheitswesen beschäftigt sich
sehr intensiv damit warum krankheiten
entstehen und wie man sie heilen kann
und das ist auch vollkommen in ordnung
wir müssen aber noch viel stärker uns
damit beschäftigen wie es gelingt dass
menschen gesund bleiben also gar nicht
erst krank werden damit wir uns nicht
falsch verstehen ist es gut und richtig
dass kranken geholfen wird so wie wir
das machen aber zusätzlich müssen wir
das gesundheitswesen stärker darauf
ausrichten menschen gesund zu erhalten
das verlangt von uns alle selbst etwas
ab die grund vorstellung man läuft eine
tablette ein und dann wird man gesund
diese grund vorstellung man muss schon
ergänzt werden durch einen weiteren
gedanken nämlich dass jeder selbst etwas
für die gesunderhaltung tun kann und
auch tun muss und dieser gedanke kommt
uns jedenfalls auch mir zu selten
ich zum beispiel nehme mir zu wenig zeit
für die eigene gesundheit
was können wir jetzt tun was heißt das
konkret
die krankenkassen bekommt da zwar
derzeit ihr geld aus dem gesundheitsfond
dafür wenn sie möglichst viele kranke
haben ist auch nachvollziehbar weil man
da auch mehrausgaben hat aber warum
geben wir nicht jenen kassen geld denen
es gelingt ihre versicherten besonders
lang gesund zu erhalten
und wie geht's jetzt gesunderhaltung das
hat was mit gesundheitskompetenz stärken
zu tun dass gesundheitskompetenz
vermittelt wird dass es mehr
schutzimpfungen gibt dass es mehr
prävention gibt und wenn ich über
prävention sprecher dann heißt das für
mich vor allem dass die prävention die
richtigen erreicht
bei unserem präventionskursen zeigt die
statistik dass sie von 81 prozent frauen
besucht werden
das spricht dafür dass frauen besonders
intelligent sind spricht aber nicht
dafür dass unsere präventionskurse
besonders intelligent sind denn dies
sollten auch gerade männer erreichen die
vielleicht gesundheitlich eher dazu
neigen dann auch angeschlagen zu sein
wir brauchen auch mehr informationen
darüber was man selbst tun kann wie man
sich gesund ernährt wie man sich mehr
bewegt wir haben in der pandemie gemerkt
dass das thema gesundheit ins
bewusstsein einer breiten öffentlichkeit
gerückt ist dass wir auch mehr über jene
themen gesprochen haben
ich hatte ein gastwirt mal angesprochen
und hat gesagt jetzt wüssten auch die
männer
wozu das waschbecken ein klo da sein
also das thema hygiene ist bei uns
einfach ein bisschen flapsig gesagt aber
es ist in das bewusstsein der menschen
angekommen dass man sich mit die kähne
mehr beschäftigen muss oder wenn ich an
das thema impfen denke das wird uns ja
in diesen tagen ganz besonders bewusst
wir haben auch auf anderen bereichen der
die grippeimpfung anschauen ist ja
positive entwicklung dass die zahl der
grippe geimpft gewachsen ist
wir sind natürlich noch immer nicht dort
wo wir hinwollen das versagen 75 prozent
der älteren möglich
impfen lassen gegen grippe aber wir sind
auf einem sehr guten weg meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren lassen sie
unsere gesundheitswesen umbauen
mit einem starken öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst wir brauchen mehr
gesundheitsförderung wir brauchen mehr
prävention wir brauchen mehr
wissensvermittlung für alle darüber was
sich selbst für ein gesundes leben tun
können vielen dank
viele länder kraus hat hier die debatte
eröffnet und ich habe es ja schon gesagt
drei anträge hat die fdp fraktion
eingereicht und der redner der nun für
diese anträge hier vorstellen und
verteidigen wird ist paul viktor bodó
sei er sitzt auch im
gesundheitsausschuss für seine fraktion
das durchsichtige nicht gesehen alles in
ordnung
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren es freut mich sehr
heute einen antrag vorzustellen
denn die afc im juni 2020 hier im
deutschen bundestag eingebracht hat und
der vor allen anderen fraktionen im
gesundheitsausschuss inklusive der
grünen abgelehnt wurde nämlich die
reform der weltgesundheitsorganisation
die grünen weltverbesserer wollen die
whu in die deutschen in die deutsche
gesundheitsversorgung einbinden
schön und gut wäre dieses vorhaben nicht
von scheinheiligkeit und doppelmoral
aufgelegt deutschland hat allein im jahr
2020 zur bewältigung der korona pandemie
397 millionen euro an freiwilligen
leistungen an die bh und hören hacks
bezahlt hier nicht eingeschlossen sind
die anderen projekte freiwillige
zahlungen unser pflichtbeitrag
international war deutschland im jahr
2020 eine größte staatliche geldgeber
der bh wenn es jedoch darum geht diese
einst so prestigeträchtige institution
zur verantwortung zu ziehen und ihre
verfehlungen zu beleuchten
ignoriert die deutsche regierung alle
alarmzeichen
[Applaus]
aber auch die übrigen
oppositionsparteien scheint hier
vollkommen ein zu blicken
vor allem die grünen doch wie aus afd
schon uns nicht davor genau dieser nicht
ende anzusprechen publik zu machen und
aufzuarbeiten 2020 bot eine galerie
schacht verfehlungen der weg im
september erschütterten ungeheuerliche
vorwürfe wegen sexuellen missbrauchs die
weltgesundheitsorganisation ihre ärzte
sollen in kongo-kinshasa wäre dafür
herren dollar epidemie von 20 18 bis
2020 frauen und mädchen systematisch
sexuell ausgebeutet haben
dieser bericht machte international
schlagzeilen scheint die hier anwesenden
gutmenschen jedoch genauso wende zu
interessieren wie die ernst zu nehmenden
hand tschuldigung gegen den bv schrift
etwas gebremst in den völkermord in
äthiopien verwickelt zu sein
die times berichtete im dezember 2020
über diesen skandal während in
deutschland nach wie vor blinder
gehorsam herrscht auch nicht unvergessen
bleibt die china zentrische das
zentrische gewarnt zu beginn der
pandemie und das unglaublich später
entsenden eines forschungsteams zur
entdeckung des ursprungs von corona der
bis heute nicht geklärt ist doch die
größte baustelle der weg ist die
finanzierung denn die einstige
finanzierung durch pflichtbeiträge der
mitglieder staaten ist schon lange passé
eingenommen haben diese rolle an der
reihe
inzwischen stammen rund 80 prozent des
haushaltes von privaten geldgebern
stiftungen und freiwilligen
regierungszuschüsse die zweckgebunden
also über die gwh und nicht frei
verfügen kann
diese akteure die den großteil der
gelder bereitstellen zu uns ist nicht
aus altruistischen motiven sondern
kaufen sie lamentieren einfluss in der
organisation
dies stößt in der forschung
zivilgesellschaft und vor allem der ard
auf massive kritik
stück für stück wurde die förderung von
basis gesundheitssystemen in den armen
ländern dieser welt zur nebensache und
durch die abhängigkeit vom geld gebannt
konterkarierte empfehlungen die
milliarden von menschen betreffen müssen
aber unabhängigen forschungsergebnissen
und entscheidungsprozessen basieren und
nicht voll angebots des höchste serie
schreiben sie nicht zeitig still des
hofs bitten der lobbyisten abhängig
um die wähler zu reformieren von der dfb
deshalb ein finanzierungsmodell das eine
industrie staaten und stiftungs
zentrierte politik unterbindet zum
zweiten die strikte einhaltung
demokratischer entscheidungsprozesse
innerhalb der bh die unabhängig von den
beitragszahlungen ist und zum dritten
letzten mal das wissenschaftlich
wissenschaftler funktionären die db
sichert die bauarbeiten gründlich auf
industrie verbundenheit und noby
tätigkeiten zu überprüfen und
gegebenenfalls nicht einzustellen
meine damen
diesen menschlichen bürokratischen sucht
mit dem geld der deutschen steuerzahler
zu finanzieren
das moralisch nicht vertretbar die welt
kann ihre verantwortungsvolle aufgabe
einen dank gewissenhaft nachgehen wenn
unabhängigkeit transparenz und
demokratische entscheidungsprozesse
gesichert sind
ohne reform sind weitere zahlungen an
dieser mittlerweile korrupte
organisation unverzüglich einzustellen
bildern paulo victor puhl hat hier die
anträge einmal vorgestellt sollen fokus
auf die bh oder fordert die fdp zum
beispiel dass angestellte überprüft
werden sollen ob zum beispiel lobby
tätigkeiten nachgewiesen werden können
nächste rednerin ist jetzt für die
sozialdemokraten hilde mattheis
sie sitzt auch im gesundheitsausschuss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
möchte über das thema sprechen was
hinter dem tagesordnungspunkt steckt
nämlich über den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst
wenn es eine lehre eine von mehreren
lehrern aus der pandemie gibt dann haben
wir doch hoffentlich gelernt dass wir
den öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
stärken müssen denn der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst ist ganz
nachgewiesener weise eine schnittstelle
eine wesentliche schnittstelle zur
bekämpfung der pandemie und wir haben in
den letzten jahrzehnten immer mal wieder
so ein hoch flocken gehabt zur
wichtigkeit des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes immer dann wenn
pandemien da waren vor etlichen jahren
wurde immer wieder gesagt wir müssen den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst stärken
es da uns heute nicht
passieren dass wir das nächste woche
wieder vergessen und daher sagten wir
als spd-fraktion
wir brauchen in der tat einen gestärkten
gesundheitsdienst nicht nur mit den
maßnahmen die wir in den letzten wochen
auf den weg gebracht haben in den
letzten monaten auf den weg gebracht
haben sondern eine nachhaltige stärkung
und schon 2016 haben ja die
gesundheitsminister der länder gesagt
wir brauchen in der tat eine stärkere
interdisziplinären und
multiprofessionellen ansatz für den npd
wir brauchen eine stärkere verzahnung
mit der wissenschaft wir wollen dass die
der bund die länder und die kommunen
verantwortung tragen
wir wollen in diesem dreiklang dass die
bevölkerung in den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst eine ansprechstelle
hat ansprechpartnerinnen ansprechpartner
hat für bestimmte gesundheitliche fragen
auch prävention in sachen prävention das
alles dürfen wir nicht vergessen und
deswegen ich bin dankbar wir sind
dankbar über den antrag der grünen aber
er geht uns nicht weit genug
und wir haben in unserem papier dass wir
miteinander in der fraktion beschlossen
haben und wofür wir werben in der tat
ein umsatz gewählt der auf die
kompetenzen des bundes erweitert denn es
ist schön was sie als grüne formuliert
haben aber es ist nicht nachhaltig genug
denn wir sehen ja jetzt wie wenig oder
wie lang es braucht um vereinbarungen um
vereinbarungen auf den weg zu bringen
sehr schnell haben wir doch alle
miteinander den ausbau von programmen
den digital ausbau für die öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienste
auf den weg gebracht mit 50 millionen
wir haben gesagt wir geben 4 milliarden
für personal
ja das ist alles gut und richtig aber
die umsetzung dauert lang weil der
föderalismus einfach auch eine hürde
darstellt und wir wollen dass es sehr
schnell geht und wir wollen dass die
umsetzung in sachen budget ausbau
personalstellen digital ausstattung und
auch akzeptanz wieder sehr viel stärker
wird und von daher liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der antrag der antrag der
grünen ist gut und wichtig aber lassen
sie uns gemeinsam auf folgenden weg
gehen ja der sachverständigenrat kann
uns wichtige hinweise geben aber
hinweise wie nicht ob sondern wie der
idee ausgebaut werden sollte und zwar so
dass er wirklich den anspruch hat einer
niedrigschwelligen anlaufstelle die auch
vorbeugend präventiv wirksam ist die
auch bei nicht nur bei hygiene konzepten
nicht nur in pandemie zeiten sondern vor
allen dingen auch bei voruntersuchungen
bei allen möglichen fragen der
bevölkerung zum thema gesundheitsschutz
zuständig ist
dazu braucht es in werben und ein
umdenken in den kommunen und in den
ländern vor allen dingen denn was haben
wir in den letzten jahrzehnten erlebt
und da will ich jetzt keine irgendwie
schelte betreiben aber es ist einfach es
gehört zur bilanz dazu der idee ist
irgendwie so ein kleiner eine kleine
fachabteilung geworden in irgendwelchen
kreis ämtern und nicht eine
selbstständige behörde die als dritte
säule in unserem gesundheitssystem
etabliert ist das müssen wir ändern das
ist nicht nur eine kleine stelle wo man
wo man herbstliches oder nicht
ärztliches personal einstellt denn die
manchen gesundheitsämtern sind auch
keine mediziner angestellt das muss man
auch dazu sagen sondern es muss eine
behörde sein und behörde ist nichts
langweiliges darf es nicht sein in dem
fall sondern es muss eine zupackende
eine auf die bevölkerung zugehen de eine
problemlösung de institution sein und
von daher möchten wir dass die
gesundheitsämter diese rolle sehr viel
stärker in unserem system einnehmen und
dafür unterstützt werden und ich werbe
dafür wir werden dafür dass der idee auf
jeden fall auch eine große bedeutung in
den parlamenten bekommt die nicht so
sehr darüber reden nämlich vielleicht in
den kreistagen und in den
länderparlamenten denn da wurde
zusammengespart ganz massiv zusammen
gespart
deshalb also auch diese stärkung diese
institutionelle stärkung ist unser
anliegen und ich habe schon gesagt 40
milliarden auf 4 milliarden 40 werden
vielleicht besser aber 4 milliarden und
50 millionen für den gd für personal für
den ausbau der digitalen infrastruktur
scheinen auf den ersten blick nicht
nicht wenig zu sein aber wenn man
nachhaltig dass sich anguckt dass das
nur ein paar jahre geht da muss man
sagen vielleicht ist das einfach zu kurz
gesprungen
deswegen wollen wir als spd-fraktion
auch die möglichkeit des bundes haben
und zwar über das eine änderung des
grundgesetzes dafür werbe ich denn das
thema daseinsvorsorge ist eines das
fundamental im bereich der gesundheit
wieder an konjunktur gewinnen muss das 1
sorge und von daher liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
ich finde wir sollten uns wirklich auf
den weg machen und in dieser situation
wo uns die pandemie gelehrt hat wo so
viele knapp stellen sind wo so viele
auch fehlt strukturen sind die nicht das
leisten können was sie in dieser
situation leisten müssten
dass wir in dieser situation nicht
einfach nach ein paar monaten sagen gott
sei dank es ist überwunden sondern wir
sagen gott sei dank jetzt müssen wir uns
vorbereiten dass wir das jetzt gelernt
haben und uns so auf den weg machen denn
der idee ist und bleibt die
schnittstelle und wir leer wir lernen
dass jeden tag nicht nur dass die zahlen
oftmals auch fehlerhaft verzögert
ankommen sondern dass die kontakt nach
verfolgungs möglichkeiten des pd einfach
nicht so sind wie wir uns das vorstellen
dass es da auch eine kleine blockade
gibt in dem ein oder anderen
gesundheitsdienst das alles müssen wir
auflösen und das geht nur wenn wir nicht
kritisieren sondern wenn wir
unterstützen deshalb der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst braucht diese
unterstützung von bund land und kreis
vielen dank
der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst dede
wurde zu viel zusammen gespart hat hilde
mattheis hier kritisiert und eigentlich
hat er ja sehr große aufgaben unter
anderem soll er die hygiene in den
krankenhäusern überwachen anderem man
spricht jetzt für die fdp fraktion meine
damen und herren in einer pandemie
erwarten wir alle einen starken
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst dazu
gehört explizit die lokalen
gesundheitsämtern und das
robert-koch-institut der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst das eis der
wichtigsten einrichtungen des staates um
einen guten gesundheits standard um
gesundheits sicherheit der bevölkerung
zu gewährleisten
doch wie es gelaufen wir mussten
erkennen dass der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst heillos überfordert
war
es waren explizit nicht meine damen und
herren die mitarbeiter und mitarbeiter
schuldig sondern schuldig waren die
länder und die kommunen denn sie haben
seit jahren in personal und ausstattung
gespart
es ging auch lange gut doch saß co2
deckte dieser versäumnisse gnadenlos auf
und hier ist der ansatz der grünen
richtig wir müssen mehr im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst tun
gesundheit darf nämlich nicht nur ein
kostenfaktor angesehen werden sondern
hier muss mehr in die zukunft in
personal und ausstattung investiert
werden
nicht die mitarbeiter und mitarbeitern
gesundheitsamt oder robert koch institut
sind die buhmänner oder buch frauen in
dieser pandemie
denn wie kann ein fisch schwimmen wenn
das wasser fehlt
und hier fehlt viel wasser hoffentlich
ziehen wir alle die richtige schlüsse
aus dieser pandemie doch bundesmittel
dort immer einzusetzen wo die länder
geschlafen haben ist nicht der richtige
weg um kein nachhaltiger einsatz ansatz
wir erwarten hier viel mehr
verantwortung auch von seiten der bund
länder bessere vernetzung und klare
aufgaben des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst sind jetzt essentiell
und wichtig um die herausforderungen in
der gesundheit herr zu werden und auf
die nächste pandemie besser vorbereitet
zu sein
so geht nachhaltige gesundheitspolitik
immer wieder auch heute war zu hören
dass lockdown maßnahmen notwendig waren
um die kontakt erfolgen nachzuvollziehen
das mag ja durchaus sein in einer
pandemie doch noch wichtiger ist nach
der kontakt verfolgung und das haben
auch staat mit deutlich besserer
instanzen gezeigt dass bessere
kontrollen und vieles hätte ersparen
können wenn in einer deutschen stadt die
menschen die unter quarantäne oder
isolierung sind nur ein prozent
kontrolliert werden und dabei 30 prozent
dieser menschen die regeln nicht
einhalten ist es kein wunder dass wir
immer wieder infektionsketten haben die
aufleuchten und uns probleme bereiten
vergleichen wir doch einmal taiwan und
korea südkorea
sie ist damit dem öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst aussieht da ist das
wirksamste mittel die kontrolle der
quarantäne und die sanierungsmaßnahmen
ein kluges vorgehen anstatt ständige
lockdown es besser übrigens als die
angst politik der bundesregierung und
wir hätten auch weniger sorgen um
motivieren so wäre uns lieber erspart
geblieben wäre wenn sie eine frage
stellen stellen sie eine frage rein
rufen ist nicht stil des hauses der
öffentliche gesundheit und die pandemie
ernst nimmt muss dann ein weiter so die
begangenen fehler erkennen und diese
umgehend beseitigen
die ausrede es gibt zu viele
interessierte ihn nicht mehr und so kann
es im öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
auch nicht weitergehen deshalb brauchen
wir einen starken öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und robert
koch-institut wir brauchen sie als
krisen spezialisten dieser beruf im
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst muss
lukratives werden mit
aufstiegsmöglichkeiten und besseren
verdienst und nicht einfach heraus mit
dankeschön das fach öffentliche
gesundheit muss auch mehr widerhall
finden in den universitären ausbildungen
wir brauchen qualitativ bessere
vernetzung durch die nutzung der
digitalen möglichkeiten
wir brauchen aber auch mehr
verantwortungsübernahme auf länder ebene
oder wir müssen damit anfangen zu
diskutieren auf eine systemwechsel haben
wollen das gesundheits richtung grund
geht
so kann meine damen und herren
öffentlicher gesundheitsdienst und
robert koch-institut verbessert werden
und unserem land besser und nachhaltiger
dienen herzlichen dank andre ullmann für
die fdp fraktion ist hier auch auf die
bekämpfung der korona pandemie
eingegangen
das bietet sich bei ihm an ist nämlich
auch infektologe nächster redner ist
harald weinberg für die linksfraktion er
ist unter anderem dort sprecher für
krankenhauspolitik und
gesundheitsförderung und prävention
da fielen dann frau präsidentin die
kolleginnen kollegen eine kollegin
zwischen hofe sind einfach ganz normale
parlamentarische gepflogenheit das will
ich noch mal darauf hinweisen vom rudolf
virchow dem armen arzt stammt die
bemerkungen dabei zitiert er salomon
neumann
die medizin ist eine soziale
wissenschaft und die politik ist weiter
nichts als medizin im großen die
richtigkeit dieser erkenntnis er
schließlich besonders in den tagen der
pandemie die wir jetzt im moment haben
die auseinandersetzung mit der pandemie
zeigt dass in der tat hat politik und
medizin zusammen gehört
gesundheit ist unser unvermindert dabei
von der sozialen lage der menschen
abhängig das war schon vorher oder so es
gibt zehn jahre unterschied in der
lebenserwartung zwischen den reichsten
und dem ärmsten zehn prozent der
bevölkerung und das im reichen
deutschland wer arm ist stirbt früher
und das ist ein skandal
und das ist auch wenn der korona
pandemie so das virus ist nicht der
große gleichmacher es trifft die ärmsten
die sozial benachteiligten weitaus
stärker als die reichen die oxfam studie
hat es gerade wieder bestätigt es ist
ein ungleiches virus und da gilt die
alte aber zutreffende regel nur die
reichen können sich einen armen staat
leisten alle anderen sind auf einen gut
funktionierenden staat mit einem gut
funktionierenden gesundheitswesen
dringend angewiesen und da das hat die
pandemie geleert ist noch einiges zu tun
wir haben es jetzt gerade gehört der
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst ist in den
letzten jahrzehnten er kaputt gespart
worden als wirklich nach vorne gebracht
worden
und es ist eine wichtige erkenntnis dass
er durchaus und das hat sich jetzt
gezeigt an der pandemie systemrelevant
ist und insofern in der tat auf allen
ebenen auch wieder bestärkt werden muss
da sind wir auch voll beim grünen antrag
erst mal an dieser stelle unser geld ist
auch die verschiedenen ebenen zu
verzahnen bund land und regionen müssen
da sozusagen zusammenkommen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es geht
aber auch um gesundheit als aufgabe in
allen politikbereichen
das ist auch adressiert in dem antrag
der grünen hält in all policies heißt
das halt eben in dem ansatz der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und dabei
geht es darum dass gesundheitliche
chancengleichheit und
gesundheitsförderung nicht einfach an
die gesundheitspolitik zu delegieren ist
sondern eine querschnittsaufgabe ist die
alle politikbereiche betrifft das
bedeutet in der wohnungspolitik das
bedeutet in der sozialpolitik in der
steuerpolitik in der finanzpolitik in
der wirtschaftspolitik in der
asylpolitik und so weiter und so fort
die voraussetzungen und die
verhältnisse zu schaffen die ihnen die
der gesundheit der menschen förderlich
ist
es ist auch relativ plausibel und
relativ klar man kann es am beispiel der
wohnungspolitik machen wenn man in einem
schlechten wohnung mit schlechter
belüftung mit schimmel im bad und so
weiter und so fort leben muss dann kann
es dort keine vernünftige gesundheit
geben die kann sich da einfach nicht
entwickeln
der antrag der grünen adressiert auch in
einem teil dieses diese frage mogelt
sich aber aus unserer sicht um eine
zentrale frage herum dabei denn
letztendlich heißt hält in all policies
auch die verteilungsfrage die frage der
einkommens- und vermögensverteilung in
zentrum zu stellen
von wilkinson und pickett am ziel zu
einer aufschlussreiche studie aus dem
jahre 2010 deren ergebnisse sich am ende
so zusammenfassen lassen gleichheit ist
besser für alle oder wie der deutsche
titel lautet gleichheit ist glück
da braucht dass unsere sich dann
allerdings mehr als in den ansonsten
guten antrag der grünen drin steht
deshalb können wir uns an dieser stelle
leider auch nur enthalten
vielen dank harald weinberg war das für
die linksfraktion kirsten cups konnte
spricht jetzt für die grünen die grünen
beziehen sich in ihrem antrag eben
besonders auf public half aber sagen
auch dass die mittel für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst erhöht
werden müssen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich nehme es ihnen von der koalition
tatsächlich ab dass sie etwas zur
stärkung des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes zur stärkung der
gesundheitsämter beitragen möchten aber
ich möchte ihnen zurufen machen
sie stellen diese regierung
die mittel aus dem pakt für den led die
sie bereitstellen das stimmt aber sie
kommen zu spät sie sind zu wenig und zu
allem überfluss sie sind befristet dass
es nicht nachhaltig mit ihren heiligen
notprogramm zur abschaffung der tabs
geräte und einsätzen der bundeswehr
versuchen sie jetzt die
funktionsfähigkeit der gesundheitsämter
zu sichern
das reicht nicht noch immer arbeiten die
mitarbeitenden in den gesundheitsämtern
weit über ihre belastungsgrenze hinweg
dadurch durch ihren hohen beitrag durch
ihre hohe arbeitsbereitschaft tragen sie
uns ganz maßgeblich durch diese pandemie
danke endlich endlich rückt der idee in
das zentrum der aufmerksamkeit und da
gehört er hin
die gesundheitsämter sind jetzt
besonders wichtig für den
infektionsschutz für die kontakt
nachverfolgung für die eindämmung dieser
pandemie der öko die hat aber auch
darüber hinaus ganz wichtige aufgaben
für die sorge um die gesundheit aller
schon vor der pandemie war der idee eine
entscheidende säule dieses
gesundheitswesens aber leider hat es
erst diese krise gebraucht um die
bedeutung der gesundheitsämter für die
sorge um unser aller gesundheit dass die
erkannt wird viel zu lange war der idee
opfer von sparzwängen der länder und der
bund hat sich bisher gar nicht gekümmert
schon lange vor beginn der pandemie hat
die suchtberatung die
lebensmittelsicherheit die
gesundheitsberichterstattung mit viel zu
wenig personal auskommen müssen
die schuleingangsuntersuchungen haben
zum teil gar nicht mehr stattgefunden
auch die zahnprophylaxe von den
gesundheitsämtern ärzten und zahnärzten
in den grundschulen ist flächendeckend
vielen stellen ausgefallen und die last
tragen die kinder vor allem die kinder
aus den familien deren eltern ist aus
verschiedensten gründen nicht schaffen
mit ihren kindern zur prophylaxe zu
gehen das darf doch so nicht bleiben
in unserem reichen land gehen die
gesundheitschancen und die
lebenserwartung zwischen armen und
wohlhabenden menschen so auseinander
das ist ein armutszeugnis auch da das
muss sich endlich ändern
und hier keine und das ist ein
entscheidender gedanke wir können gut
ausgestattete gesundheitsämter einen
erheblichen beitrag leisten diese
pandemie ist schwierig sie bringt viele
von uns an den rand ihrer kräfte
wir können aber auch wenn wir bereit
sind wirklich wenn zugucken lernen wir
können aus dieser pandemie auch lernen
was wir künftig besser machen müssen
diese krise zeigt uns dass unsere
gesundheit nicht nur von uns individuell
abhängt sondern dass unsere
lebensbedingungen unsere umwelt
entscheidend für unsere gesundheit ist
sie lehrt uns dass wir die sorge um die
gesundheit aller publicis endlich
stärker verankern müssen so wie es in
vielen ländern schon längst der fall ist
sie zeigt uns dass wir starke und gut
vernetzte paprika institutionen brauchen
und hier liegt die entscheidende chance
für den led der zukunft die
gesundheitsämter brauchen
und auf dauer eine stabile finanzierung
und dafür schlagen wir in unserem antrag
vor die ausgaben für den öbb dauerhaft
mindestens zu verdoppeln
und wenn diese basis gesichert ist dann
kann endlich besser in die
interprofessionelle publicis konzepte
und die kooperation mit kitas schulen
sportvereinen investiert werden der led
kann dann mehr in die
gesundheitsförderung vor ort einbezogen
werden so so stärken wir
gesundheitschancen aller nachhaltig
diese pandemie wird nicht die letzte
sein
wir müssen uns besser wappnen wir
brauchen ein gesundheitscheck für alle
politischen entscheidungen wir müssen
bei jeder politischen entscheidungen
überprüfen welche gesundheitlichen
auswirkungen sie hat denn opfers oder
agrarpolitik ob sozial oder
bildungspolitik alle politischen
entscheidungen haben einen einfluss auf
unsere gesundheit
und wenn wir nicht endlich zu
konsequenten umwelt und klimaschutz
übergehen steigt die gefahr weiterer
pandemien für eine gute
gesundheitsversorgung ist es
elementar wichtig dass wir künftig nicht
mehr auf das präventionsprogramm
hereinfallen
je besser die arbeit der
gesundheitsämter sein wird des
öffentlichen desto besser der
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
funktioniert hier stärker public hat je
nachhaltiger die gesundheitsförderung
desto weniger sichtbar wird in zukunft
die akute notwendigkeit von
gesundheitsämtern seien dann aber dann
aber dürfen wir nicht zulassen dass
wieder der rotstift angesetzt wird denn
das würde sich spätestens in der
nächsten krise rechnen
in unserem antrag steht was wir sofort
tun können was wir sofort tun sollten um
den öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst zudem
zu entwickeln was er sein kann
ich danke ihnen vielen dank
[Applaus]
tino sorge wird als nächstes für die
unions fraktion sprechen er sitzt wie
tatsächlich bisher alle redner in dieser
debatte im gesundheitsausschuss frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich muss ja sagen im ergebnis sind die
uns hier das hab ich zumindest den aus
erhöhung der vorrednerin und redner
entnommen alle einig dass wir den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst stärken
müssen dass wir den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst stärken wollen
der antrag der fraktion die grünen liegt
ja jetzt auch schon ein bisschen zurück
datiert vom 18 11
und insofern ist da natürlich auch viel
dabei was relativ allgemein ist ist aber
auch viel dabei was längst schon
überholt ist und wir haben ja am
mittwoch im ausschuss dazu debattiert
und ich fand das schon bemerkenswert
dass wir im ausschuss sieht man ja
selten so wohl fast einheitlich aus der
opposition
hört haben and roll man hat
beispielsweise gesagt der antrag
enthalte planwirtschaftliche elemente
auch aus der fraktion die linke als paar
weinberg sprach davon viel zu unkonkret
viel zu offen und präzise also dass im
grunde auch im hinblick auf die qualität
und die inhaltliche ausrichtung des
antrags wir sicherlich auch einig sind
dass der in der form nicht zielführend
und ich will auch noch einmal darauf
hinweisen dass das thema stärkung des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienstes auch
natürlich damit zusammen hängt dass wir
da vieles besser machen müssen aber ich
weigere mich immer ein bisschen dagegen
immer nur zu nörgeln also wir haben das
ja heute wieder gehört die haben für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst 4
milliarden euro zusätzlich zur verfügung
gestellt 800 millionen zusätzlich für
digitalisierung 5.000 neue stellen und
das wird hier so lapidar vom tisch
gewischt wird dann gesagt naja 14 wir
die aufnehmen wäre besser gewesen
also insofern glaube ich sollte man da
auch mal ein bisschen die relation sehen
und was ich auch noch sagen will
natürlich müssen wir den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst stärken wir wollen
dass alle aber ich persönlich möchte
nicht dass wir ein staatliches
gesundheitsamt als bundesoberbehörde
etablieren wie das bei einigen
rednerinnen und rednern hier
herausgekommen ist also ganz herzliches
dankeschön an die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter in den gesundheitsämtern vor
ort ja ich weiß die lage ist sehr
unterschiedlich dort aber ich glaube das
sollten auch deren leistung nicht
kleinreden und sagt na ja wir machen am
besten eine bundesoberbehörde und dann
wird alles besser
wir haben natürlich das thema
föderalismus angesprochen da geht es
tatsächlich darum die länder zu
unterstützen oder ist es glaube ich
nicht der richtige weg immer zu sagen
wir können mit geld alle probleme lösen
wir kippen einfach genügend geld rein
dann geht es einem besser dann läuft das
sondern wir müssen die länder konkret
dabei unterstützen wie sie ihre
gesundheitsämter zu ort besser in die
lage versetzen auch in epidemischen
lagen wie jetzt in der korona pandemie
infektionsketten nachzuverfolgen und da
ist ja schon viel auf den weg gebracht
worden
natürlich hätte ich mir gewünscht dass
wir dem ist romas also das melde- und
informationssystem schon viel viel
schneller flächendeckend etabliert
hätten
wenn man schaut dass in
afrika im kongo in nigeria thomas
bereits flächendeckend läuft das also in
afrikanischen stadien staaten systeme
genutzt werden noch dazu die wir in
deutschland entwickelt haben das ist ja
nicht vom himmel gefallen das haben wir
dann helmholtz-institut für
infektionsforschung in braunschweig ist
ja sowas entwickelt worden
da ist es natürlich nicht schön dass wir
jetzt noch darüber diskutieren ob alle
öffentlichen gesundheitsämter dieses
system nutzen ich bin froh dass
mittlerweile 375 gesundheitsämter dieses
system zumindest für die meldung nutzen
können die hälfte auch schon
angeschlossen ist und den weg sollten
wir weiter gehen dann glaube ich sind
wir da auch auf dem richtigen weg und
weil hier auch die staatsministerin für
digitalisierung sitzt will ich auch
nochmal ansprechen
mich ärgert in der ganzen diskussion
immer dass wir über digitalisierung sehr
abstrakt treten da wird dann gesagt ja
wir können mit digitalisierung viel mehr
erreichen
wir müssen nur besser vernetzen wir
müssten die institutionen die akteure in
die lage versetzen über datennutzung
über datenaustausch auch schneller auf
neue situationen zu reagieren
und genau da hakt es ja häufig wir haben
das problem dass wir grundsätzlich immer
sagen ja digitalisierung ist gut aber
wenn es dann konkret ist reden wir alles
schlecht da werden dann probleme
aufgezeigt da wird werden risiken
aufgezeigt wird die chancen getrieben
diskutiert und insofern glaube ich
stellt die pandemie insofern auch eine
chance dar
ich wünsche mir dass wir viel viel
offener auch über ideen über
möglichkeiten gerade digitale
möglichkeiten sprechen
wir müssen auch darüber sprechen
inwieweit vielleicht in dem ein oder
anderen bereichen mehr pragmatismus auch
einzug halten muss bei der abwägung
welche potentiellen möglichkeiten uns
auch eine bessere daten nutzen eröffnet
und insofern sollten die auch in der
debatte auch bei der frage wie können
wir öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
verpassen lassen sie noch eine
zwischenfrage
nicht ausschließlich nur über geld reden
wenn sie so nett fragen sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin vielen dank ich habe
jetzt abhaken okay die abholer
christmann hat das wort ja vielen dank
frau präsidentin die war kollege sie
haben so schön über digitalisierung und
ihre möglichkeiten gesprochen im bereich
der gesundheit und das treibt uns ja
derzeit alle um
wenn sie jetzt aber sagen wir sollten da
mehr über die chancen sprechen irritiert
mich dass etwas weil ich glaube über die
chancen der korona waren es zum beispiel
durch die ergänzung einer cluster
erkennung über die chancen der
digitalisierung der gesundheitsämter
sind der seit letztem sommer im gespräch
dann gab es einen hacker sein wo mehrere
lösungen für gesundheitsämter und andere
sachen vorgeschlagen worden sind all
diese dinge sind doch aus meiner sicht
von der regierung nicht zügig umgesetzt
worden
es ist ja nicht so dass nicht alle diese
chancen sehen und auch einfordern würden
sondern es mangelt noch an der umsetzung
das will ich gerne dem entgegen setzen
da sie hier für mehr begeisterung
geworben haben
wir sind alle begeistert aber wann geht
es denn los der liebe kollegin dr
christmann
wir haben hier das thema auch in der
enquetekommission künstliche intelligenz
hoch und runter diskutiert ich glaube
wir vielleicht wir beide sind uns da
noch einige als das vielleicht die die
die fraktion im in gänze sind aber das
ist ein sehr schönes stichwort weil sie
die korona waren app ansprechen also ich
kann mich daran erinnern dass wir in
deutschland wirklich wochen lang hoch
und runter diskutiert haben ob man so
eine app überhaupt machen soll ob
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen da
nicht wieder zu forschen ist ob er nicht
einfach vor gericht das sind
datenschutzbedenken angeführt worden
wir reden hier wie gesagt über eine
tracing ab da wurde so getan als würden
die leute ständig überwacht werden und
das ist genau der punkt wir reden über
innovative ideen und die werden dann
aber immer kaputt geredet und das ist ja
nicht nur bei der korona waren er zog es
ist ja bei der telematikinfrastruktur im
gesundheitswesen genau dasselbe spiel
gewesen ich kann mich darin
im rahmen des bvg des digitalen
versorgungsgesetzes da haben wir darüber
gesprochen ob wir im rahmen des
forschungs datenzentrum zentrums also wo
die daten gesammelt werden überhaupt
eine antragsbefugnis für
gesundheitsunternehmen also für private
unternehmen eine antragsbefugnis
etablieren damit die daten wird auch
genutzt werden können für forschung und
da kann ich mich sehr genau daran
erinnern dass ihre fraktion ich will
jetzt keine namen konkret nennen kann
ich aber gerne nachreichen den popanz
aufgebaut hat und hat so getan als
würden jetzt alle patienten alle
menschen gläsern sein als würde man von
jedem die privatdaten klarnamen und was
auch immer abgreifen wollen
und genau das ist der punkt dass sie
über digitalisierung immer schön blumig
erzählen aber dann wenn es konkret wird
wenn wir als parlament als
regierungsfraktion als bundesregierung
als bundesgesundheitsminister
ministerium agieren dann ist immer alles
schlecht dann ist alles böse oder
wahlweise es ist mit der gießkanne
gemacht also da müssen sie sich langsam
mal entscheiden
dann würde uns das auch konstruktiv
helfen vielen dank frau präsident ich
habe jetzt noch eine sekunde aber wenn
frau klein schweiz meldet sich gerade
das ich gerne zu sprechen sie da muss
ich natürlich darauf an eingehen weil
sie haben mich ja indirekt eigentlich
angesprochen
sie machen hier wiederholt etwas was in
der sache überhaupt nicht zutrifft nicht
der datenschutz ist dafür verantwortlich
dass sowohl die korona waren ihr
potenzial nicht ausfüllen kann wie es
eigentlich nötig wäre
oder aber auch wir mit der forschung und
dem auswerten von gesundheitsdaten für
die forschung nicht vorankommen sondern
das hat damit zu tun dass die
voraussetzungen dafür nicht passend
gestellt
geschaffen werden und wenn ich sie mal
fragen darf nennen sie uns doch mal das
datum wann endlich die cluster erkennung
für die korona waren es dann
funktionsfähig sein wird nachdem das
schon seit oktober im gespräch ist und
ganz konkrete vorschläge auf dem tisch
also ich finde das immer sehr
interessant das ist das da offenkundig
auch bei ihnen eine sehr einseitige
betrachtungsweise vorherrscht da wird
weiß das thema corona wann explizit
angesprochen wurde immer so getan als
sei man sich da einigen als können wir
sofort loslegen
das problem ist eben nur wenn wir dann
loslegen dann kommen zusätzliche
bedenken
und ich sage jetzt auch mal bei der
frage wie wir solche apps oder wieder
innovative ideen für das system
gesundheitssystem überhaupt erstmal zum
laufen bringen
da haben wir ja ständig die diskussion
inwieweit man da überhaupt akteure
einbeziehen kann
da sind sie ja meistens ganz weit vorne
weg und sagen wir müssen mehr
digitalisieren und wenn es dann aber
darum geht innovationen im system zu
ermöglichen sind sie die ersten die
bremsen weil sie sagen da dürfen private
nicht in das system rein da müssen so
hohe hürden aufgebaut werden und ich
weiß nicht die redezeit ich habe aber
ich könnte jetzt hier stundenlang auch
über das agieren des bfd ii des
bundesbeauftragten für den datenschutz
in der informationstechnologie
sprechender ja teilweise auch ein sehr
ambivalentes verhältnis zu bestimmten
digitalen lösungen hat und wenn wir in
deutschland immer meinen immer dann wenn
eine staatliche lösung angeboten wird
dann müssen wir die staatlichen lösung
150 prozentig machen also so
unpraktikabel zum schluss dass überhaupt
nicht mehr funktioniert und danach dann
kritisieren dass sie nicht funktioniert
da ist irgendwas verkehrt also da
sollten sie sich auch mal ein bisschen
überlegen diese argumentieren damit ist
die frage von frau klein schmeink von
bündnis 90/grüne beantwortet und sie
haben noch wenige sekunden zu einem
wunderbaren schluss vor der herr wird
seine zeit ist abgelaufen
hatten wir zwei uns dann aber insofern
darf ich nicht für die aufmerksamkeit
bedanken ich freue mich auf die
diskussion im ausschuss und die frage im
nachgang oder kann ich dem kollegen von
nutzern sicherlich auch noch hoffentlich
zufriedenstellend erklären freue mich
auf die beratungen und dass wir in der
digitalisierung und bei der bekämpfung
des cola virus der ausstattung der
verbesserung der öffentliche
gesundheitsämter schnell und gut
vorankommen in diesem sinne unter
diskussion viele neue bekämpfung der
korona diskussion ist ja auch ein thema
mit dem sich der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst auseinandersetzt und
jens spahn mal sehen ihn gerade der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat deswegen
auch letztes jahr im september nimmt
pakt für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst auf den weg gebracht
indem eben genau diese öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst mehr geld mehr
personal und auch eine digitale
arbeitsweise bekommen soll wynands
schoenenburg jetzt für die fdp sind als
ämter sind zuständig für die kontakt
nach vorne die aufnahme und verwaltung
von daten
wir alle wissen dass das nicht optimal
läuft würde es optimal laufen dann
könnten wir es nicht gehen locker
umgehen wenn wir nämlich einen besseren
kontakt nachverfolgen hätten könnten wir
uns mehr infektionen verlaufen als das
derzeit so ist soweit stimmen die in
vollkommen zu nun haben wir einen sehr
blumigen antrag der grünen und
verschiedene beiträge von spd und grünen
wie wichtig und wie schön und wie toll
doch der gesundheitsdienst ist ja da
müsste man annehmen
dort wo rot-grün regiert ist dann alles
ganz toll mit dem idee lass uns mal den
praxistest machen lassen sie praxistest
in meinem wahlkreis hamburg wandsbek
machen
aber wann spec wird seit sieben jahren
rot-grün regiert die stadt hamburg seit
6 jahren rot-grün regiert die fdp
fraktion der bezirksversammlung hamburg
wandsbek hat mal eine anfrage zum
gesundheitsamt hamburg wandsbek gestellt
die wurde vor wenigen tagen beantwortet
ich darf ihn mal kurz die wichtigsten
und erschreckenden antworten
mitteilen erstens die aufnahme von daten
von ärzten und von laboren wird mit
einem system offenbar selbst gestrickten
system das sich oft uwe nennt im
gesundheitsamt aufgenommen von da geht
es ja zu landesebene in hamburg dort
wird es übertraf ein anderes system das
nennt sich service net und von diesem
letzt wiederum wird ist aber die gehen
ans lka
das verstehe ich nicht unter effiziente
arbeitsweise meine damen und herren es
wäre sinnvoll gleich das system dem ist
zu verwenden zweitens wie wer folgt die
kontakt nachverfolgen 100 hamburg
wandsbek
auch dort gibt es einen eigenen selbst
gestricktes programm das nennt sich
hamburger pandemie manager
ich empfehle ein pate system sommers zu
nehmen drittes ergebnis wir haben das
bezirksamt gefragt wir hatten das alles
entschieden dass mit selbstgestrickten
eigenartigen systemen gearbeitet wird
antwort das wurde über bezüglich
entschieden dass eine nette beschreibung
dafür dass der rot grüne hamburger senat
ist nicht auf die reihe kriegt er denn
so sieht die realität in rot grün
regierten verwaltung aus darum sollten
sich mal kümmern und rot grüne träume
prallen radikal auf die realität das ist
das wahre und das muss geändert werden
meine damen und herren
nur jeder sollte auch noch weiter vor
wenigen tagen ist nun die leiterin des
gesundheitsamtes hamburg wandsbek
zurückgetreten sie hat die konsequenz
daraus gezogen dass sie offen darf eine
rot grünen verwaltung allein gelassen
wurde
mai nahmen wir als fdp wollen konkrete
verbesserung wir wollen die
flächendeckenden einsatz von dem ist und
auch von sommers dafür sollten die
sorgen und nicht so schöne anträge
schreiben mit vier blumen äußerungen
letzte bemerkung unserer bezirksfraktion
in landsberg wird ihrem rot-grünen
bezirksamt weiter auf die finger gucken
und das ist wahrscheinlich nicht
angenehm für sie vielen dank
wieland schinnenburg war das für die fdp
und der nächste redner ist stefan
pischinger ersetzt im ausschuss für
gesundheit arbeitet aber auch noch wenn
er nicht hier im bundestag ist
tatsächlich noch als
in seinem bezirk frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren die korona krise hat
uns auch im jahr 2021 noch immer fest im
griff
durch die konsequente umsetzung der
kontakt beschränkungen und die
begonnenen impfungen sind wir aber
endlich auf einem guten weg erstmals
seit beginn der zweiten pandemie phase
sinkt die zahl der täglich gemeldeten
neuinfektionen
aber wir dürfen das nun erreichte nicht
leichtfertig verspielen noch immer liegt
die sieben tage incidence bundesweit
über dem wert von 50 neue infektionen
auf 100000 einwohner
zudem drohen deutlich ansteckender virus
varianten den fortschritt zunichte zu
machen erst wenn die gesundheitsämter
wieder eine realistische chance haben
infektionskette nachzuverfolgen und zu
unterbrechen können wir die kontrolle
über das infektionsgeschehen
zurückzuerlangen
damit ist der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst ganz ohne zweifel eine
der tragenden säulen unserer pandemie
bekämpfung ohne die gesundheitsämter vor
ort wäre eine rückverfolgung von
kontakten noch eine koordinierte
vorgehensweise bei lokalen ausbrüchen
möglich an dieser stelle geht daher
zunächst man ausdrücklicher dank an alle
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
gesundheitsämtern die seit beginn dieser
pandemie unter einer bisher nie
dagewesenen belastung stehen
ich finde diese mitarbeiter haben einen
hervorragenden job geleistet
wir wissen dass die gesundheitsämter man
aktuell sehr viel abverlangt wird aber
wir werden in zukunft auch dafür sorgen
dass sie nicht nur personell gestärkt
und modernisiert werden sondern durch
eine digitale offensive war auch
untereinander besser vernetzt werden
wir haben aus dieser krise gelernt meine
damen und herren deshalb stellt der bund
den gesundheitsämtern mit dem pakt für
den öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst 4
milliarden euro zur verfügung der erste
schritt zur umsetzung dieser beschlüsse
wurde bereits mit dem dritten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz hier im
deutschen bundestag gemacht mit hilfe
dieser neuen regelungen werden dringend
notwendigen maßnahmen zur stärkung des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst endlich
konkret umgesetzt
noch bis ende dieses jahres sollen auf
dieser grundlage mindestens 1.500 neue
stellen geschaffen werden
dh
ärztinnen und ärzte aber auch mehrfach
und verwaltungspersonal bis ende des
kommenden jahres sollen darüber hinaus
mindestens 3500 weitere vollzeitstellen
in den gesundheitsämtern geschaffen
werden
auch die attraktivität einer tätigkeit
in den gesundheitsämtern soll im rahmen
dieser maßnahmen künftig steigen denn
bei der besetzung von stellen steht der
idee in direkter konkurrenz zu anderen
bereichen des gesundheitswesens durch
eine engere verzahnung mit der forschung
stärken wir aber gleichzeitig auch die
wissenschaftliche basis des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes meine damen und
herren
sie sehen wir haben innerhalb kürzester
zeit zahlreiche wirksame maßnahmen
angestoßen und auch bereits mit der
konkreten umsetzung begonnen
natürlich werden wir aber nicht von
heute auf morgen die personellen und
organisatorischen strukturen der
gesundheitsämter vollständig
modernisieren können wir wollen diese
krise möglichst bald überwinden aber die
maßnahmen benötigen zeit um zu wirken
seien sie versichert wir tun alles dafür
damit die verbesserungen so schnell wie
möglich vor ort ankommen
meine damen und herren ich glaube wir
haben bei der verbesserung des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienstes keine
zeit zu verlieren nach meiner meinung
kommt die dritte welle sicher ich gebe
der kanzlerin recht die öffnungen in den
schulen durch die bundesländern sind
verfrüht
wir werden sehr schnell mit dem märz den
zeitpunkt haben dass wir wieder einen
exponentiellen wachstum sind deswegen
brauchen wir einen öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst der die kontakt
verfolge bis dahin sicher nachvollziehen
kann denn einen weiteren lockdown
sollten wir unter allen umständen
vermeiden auch wenn dies unter der
jetzigen betrachtung als sehr
schwieriger scheint vielen dank
[Applaus]
stefan pischinger war dass die cdu/csu
der vorletzte redner in dieser debatte
ist edgar franke für die
sozialdemokraten hoch verehrte frau
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren gute medizinische versorgung
ist heute ein stück lebensqualität vor
ort das ist vielen leuten vielen
menschen wichtig deshalb brauchen wir
ein dichtes netz aus kliniken aber aus
niedergelassenen erster und aus
gesundheitsämtern und das überall nicht
nur in den ballungszentren
gerade in ländlichen gegenden ist dieses
netz aber häufig nicht enkeln doch wir
wissen alle kommunen suchen händeringend
nach hausärzten kleinere kliniken vor
ort haben es schwer und jeder der
kommunalpolitisch tätig ist ein kreistag
in den kommunen weist gesundheitsämtern
fehlt es an personal den
gesundheitsämtern fehlt es aber ganz
häufig auch an geld das wissen wir
eigentlich nicht erst seit der pandemie
für die menschen heißt das eine gute
gesundheitsversorgung ist nicht mehr
überall selbstverständlich für uns
sozialdemokraten ist gesundheit das
höchste gut und gesundheit meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren darf eben
nicht vom sozialen status abhängen und
harald weinberg hat zu recht gesagt es
darf nicht sein dass wer arm ist früher
stirbt und deswegen ist für die uns
sozialdemokraten die öffentliche
daseinsvorsorge gesundheit eines der
wichtigsten gesellschaftlichen punkte
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
deshalb haben wir auch die
flächendeckende gesundheitsversorgung
uns immer auf die fahnen geschrieben wir
haben ja auch ein bisschen was gemacht
mit dem krankenhaus zukunfts gesetz
machen wir unsere kliniken zukunftsfest
der bund stellt drei milliarden euro für
digitalisierung und moderne
notfallversorgung bereit damit stärken
wir nicht nur die kranken
dass auch die krankenhäuser vor ort auf
dem land sondern wir stärken auch die
konjunktur zweitens wir stärken die
bedarfs- notwendigen krediten auf dem
land das war mir persönlich ganz ganz
wichtig sie bekommen eine jährliche
bundesförderung wir haben sie erst
erhöht auf
wie soll ich sagen auf politischen
initiative auch der spd damit können
kliniken jetzt bis zu 800.000 euro
zusätzlich erhalten auch das war ein
ganz großer politischer erfolg meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wir
würden uns als sozialdemokraten zwar
noch wünschen herr minister dass die
förderkriterien für bedarf wird wenn die
kliniken vielleicht noch ein bisschen
offener gestaltet werden vielleicht noch
ein bisschen mehr sich an den
versorgungs realitäten anpassen aber das
ist gut
drittens seit diesem jahr gibt es ein
den takt für öffentlichen den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst der
länder halten 4 milliarden es ist mehr
fahrt strom gesagt worden werden 5.000
neue stellen bekommen hilde mattheis hat
sehr kenntnisreich und ist in dem
bereich schon lange sehr sehr engagiert
auch ausgeführt dass wir den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst personell
stärken müssen dass wir den innerlich
stärken müssen und dafür den
konzeptionell stärken müssen und das ist
der richtige weg
und sie hat auch zu recht gesagt es muss
ein umdenken geben umdenken bei den
kommunen bei den ländern bei den
landkreisen dass öffentlicher
gesundheitsdienst ich nicht nur ein
anhängsel ist sondern dass dort politik
gemacht wird und zwar kaputt konto hat
gesagt vorstellen mit den zahnprophylaxe
nur aus einem beispiel zu nehmen der
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst ist
wichtig für die daseinsvorsorge
insofern sollten wir alle daran arbeiten
ihn weiter zu stärken
meine sehr verehrten damen und mit all
diesen maßnahmen werden wir unsere
unseren öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
aber nicht nur den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst sondern auch in
zukunft die gesundheitliche versorgung
stärken
ich möchte aber auch noch den ambulanten
bereich zum schluss noch
sprechen weil ein antrag sich auch auf
die faz bezieht die ambulante
medizinische versorgung ist auch
sozusagen im gesellschaftlichen wandel
begriffen dass der gesellschaftliche
wandel wirkt sich auch darauf aus
deswegen haben wir seit knapp 20 jahren
jahr die sogenannten medizinischen
versorgungszentren die sogenannten mvz
wir wissen alle in diesen zentren
arbeiten erste zusammen unter einem dach
oft aus unterschiedlichen fachrichtungen
die mvz haben sich wirklich bewährt sie
haben oftmals die medizinische
versorgung vor ort verbessert und sie
bieten auch vorteile für gerade menschen
oder ärztinnen und ärzte die teilzeit
arbeiten wollen sie bieten auch vorteile
das da oder andere arzt folge sagt ich
möchte kein wirtschaftliches risiko mehr
tragen und seit der letzten
legislaturperiode können wir auch
tatsächlich rechtlich selbstständige mvz
von kommunen betreiben lassen und
gründen und können so gezielt die
medizinische versorgung stärken und in
meinem landkreis in hessen habe ich mich
vor zwei jahren sehr dafür eingesetzt es
gibt nur eine handvoll menschen
versorgungsform die von kommunen
betrieben werden in einer stadt
schwarzenborn hat 1000 einwohnern die
kleinste stadt in hessen 1000 einwohner
ist wirklich nicht viel aber da war kein
arzt männer dort hat die kommune ein
kommunales mvz gegründet wo ärzte zwei
ärztin seine gynäkologin ein hausarzt
angestellt sind dort gibt es jetzt ein
arzt es gibt es eine ärztin und da sieht
man ganz konkret also mvz und da wo es
keine erste gibt auch kommunale mvz sind
ein wichtiges instrument flächendeckende
versorgung herzustellen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
deshalb sollten wir gerade mvz stärken
sie sind hervorragend geeignet die
ambulante medizinische versorgung auch
in ländlichen regionen zu verbessern
sind ein wichtiger baustein für eine
flächendeckende versorgung eine gute
versorgung wie wir immer sagen
unabhängig vom alter der versicherten
unabhängig vom geldbeutel und unabhängig
vom wohnort das ist der rote faden
sozialdemokratischer gesundheitspolitik
dankeschön
doch franke war das für die spd fraktion
und damit kommen wir zum letzten redner
in dieser debatte georg kippels sitzt
auch im gesundheitsausschuss und ist
mitglied der unionsfraktion präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wir
haben in der letzten stunde jetzt
leidenschaftliche plädoyers für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst gehört
durchaus auch herbe und an einigen ecken
auch ohne weiteres berechtigte kritik
der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst ist
durch die pandemie seit einem jahr
nunmehr im unmittelbaren fokus der
gesamten bevölkerung und natürlich auch
der politik und ich glaube uns eint ihr
alle die überzeugung dass gute arbeit
geleistet wurde verbesserungsbedarf da
ist und wir uns diesem alle widmen
sollten für eine saubere aufarbeitung
dieser fragestellung glaube ich ist es
aber auch wichtig dass wir zwischen zwei
verschiedenen aspekten des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst unterscheiden sorgen
auf der einen seite die regelversorgung
viele aspekte sind angesprochen worden
prävention aufklärung regeln
untersuchungen in weesen hygiene und auf
der anderen seite natürlich die
einsatztätigkeit in der bewältigung
einer pandemie in einer krise in eine
ausnahme situation alles das geht
zusammen beim öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und insofern bin ich
der meinung dass diese aspekte
im antrag der kollegen der grünen leider
unzureichend beleuchtet worden sind
nicht nur gerne die den auslöser der
pandemie einmal zum anlass nehmen
exemplarisch die herausforderung für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst anhand
meiner meines heimat kreises das rhein
erft reisen sind nordrhein westfalen mit
465.000 einwohnern und zehn städten
konkret darstellen
die inzidenz war heute morgen bei 71,8
in den zehn städten ist aber das
spektrum zwischen 40 und 100 21 wir
haben 587 infizierte und wir beklagen
und betrauern 296 verstorbenen das gibt
mir zunächst einmal anlass von hier aus
einen gruß in die heimat zu senden und
dem landrat frank rock und auf dem
gesundheitsdezernenten christian
eddersheim und seinen kolleginnen und
dem team der verwaltung herzlich dank zu
sagen über die wichtige aufgabenstellung
der kontakt nachverfolgen erfolgreich
bewältigt worden ist aber wie sieht wie
sieht die personelle besetzung aus aus
dem normalbetrieb kommend 85 mitarbeiter
für 60 stellen fünf mediziner auf der
leitungsebene ein verwaltungsbeamter
mittlerweile sind es in der
sondersituation alleine 85 mitarbeiter
im coffee zentrum in der kürze der zeit
natürlich nicht durch vollwertige
neueinstellungen und zu besetzen sondern
umsetzungen und abordnungen waren
erforderlich
des weiteren 95 externe mitarbeiter aus
den anderen behörden und der bundeswehr
frage ist das nun ein strukturelles
problem der unterbesetzung nein
selbstverständlich nicht weil es eine
ausnahme situation ist allerdings
richtig ist auch dass für den
regelbetrieb der personalstand im laufe
der jahre immer weiter heruntergegangen
ist auch deshalb weil viele auch vor
allem vorsorgemaßnahmen in der
vergangenheit in den privaten bereich
ausgelagert wurden
ich nenne nur mal exemplarisch die so
genannten u-untersuchungen die jetzt mit
tatkräftiger unterstützung der gkv bei
den kinder ärzten stattfinden und die
klassischen reihenuntersuchungen und
rein in so genannte ich mich auch noch
gut aus meiner kinderzeit erinnern kann
überhaupt nicht mehr stattfinden wir
müssen also für die attraktivierung des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst wieder
originäre medizinische
aufgabenstellungen suchen und etablieren
wodurch natürlich auch die attraktivität
für die mediziner selbst in diese
berufssparte einzusteigen steigt und
auch die weiteren fragestellungen die
aus der krise resultierende ich müssen
wir im besonderen maße ins auge nehmen
wir haben festgestellt dass zur
bewältigung zu beginn der krise aber
auch im weiteren verlauf eine sehr
intensive zusammenarbeit zwischen
hauptamt auf der einen seite der idee
und dem ehrenamt drk johanniter malteser
caritas stattgefunden hat und
stattfinden musste um bestimmte
punktuelle aufgabenstellungen personell
aufzufangen hier wäre es aus meiner
sicht eine wichtige aufgabenstellung
diesen trainingsbetrieb zu verstetigen
uns so geben so wie es die bundeswehr
thw und die feuerwehr macht
krisenszenarien im wiederkehr
wiederkehrenden rhythmus zu erproben
einzuüben zu harmonisieren und vor allen
dingen auch die technischen
gegebenheiten zu vervollständigen und zu
perfektionieren
wir haben schon die bei den vorrednern
zahlreiche hinweise zu den digitalen
hilfsmitteln gehört diese müssen aber
auch tatsächlich im zusammenspiel
funktionieren
der pakt von bundesländern für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst vom 5
september 2020 stellt dafür eine
hervorragende basis dar
wir sollten jetzt nicht in aktionismus
verfallen sondern wir müssen nach der
pandemie auch eine solide analyse des
bedarfs ermitteln wir müssen die inhalte
schärfen und
apr aktivieren und dafür stellt der pakt
ausreichend mittel und ressourcen zur
verfügung infolgedessen müssen wir uns
dem antrag nicht mit win und können ihn
getrost ablehnen fielen nach zwischen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit und das war
dann die debatte über den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und wir beenden auch
damit unsere übertragung der
sitzungswoche in dieser woche
übernächste woche steht die nächsten
plenarsitzung an da wird es auch um die
gesundheitsversorgung oder auch wieder
um die korona steuerhilfen gehen